- It takes courage to win!
People don't talk about
people that don't win!
If you win, they're
going to talk about you.
You've wasted too much of your life
trying to change other
people's mind about you.
Don't tell me that you want something
if you're not willing to throw
what you got at it.
- Hello Believe Nation!
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe,
and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from
pastor and thought leader
Bishop T.D. Jakes,
and my take on his top
10 rules for success,
volume two.
Rule number 10 is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
You might win a prize as well.
And also when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(airplane soars)
(instrumental music)
- Do you have the courage
to act outwardly
on what you see inwardly?
(audience cheers)
Or will you die a dreamer?
Will you die on the verge and on the edge
in the land of could have,
would have, and should have?
The strong hand rules the roost.
Do you have the courage?
I'm going to drop something on you.
It takes courage to be successful.
It is far easier not to be successful.
Misery will always have company.
(audience cheer)
Success breeds contempt.
If you don't want to
make waves, be mediocre.
Be normal and fit in.
And if you're more concerned about people
then you are God,
then neutralize everything He put in you
just fit in with everybody else.
Dress like 'em!
Walk like 'em!
Act like 'em!
Eat like 'em!
Go where they go!
Think like they think!
Do what they do!
And once you've
neutralized your uniqueness
you don't need courage.
It takes courage to be different
It takes courage to go where
you've never gone before.
For some of you it took courage
to come to this conference.
It takes courage to get
you outside of the bar.
It takes courage to be successful!
It takes courage to win!
People don't talk about
people that don't win.
If you win they're
going to talk about you!
Do you have the courage to stand there,
though the storms keep raging,
and the people get to talkin,
and you stand there and
say, I've come to far
to turn around!
Touch your girlfriend and
say, do you have the courage?
- [Audience] Do you have the courage?
(applause)
- I'm going to say something to you.
It takes courage to be exceptional.
It takes courage to be wise.
It takes courage to be rich.
It takes courage to be educated.
It takes courage to be knowledgeable.
Because the moment you do,
but you don't talk like,
Oh, you forgot where you
came from, look at you.
It takes courage!
(audience cheers)
And I'm just wondering
In this weak, watered
down, mediocre society
that we live in today.
In this reality TV world we live in today.
I'm wondering if there's anybody left
that's got the courage
to say after all I've been through,
and all my ancestors have been through,
and all my parents have been through,
I didn't come through all of that
just to fit in with normalcy,
I have the courage
to go after my dream!
To be anxious is to have
anxiety about something
that hadn't even happened yet.
Some of you are so worried
about the threat of trouble.
You're not in trouble
it's just that trouble has threatened you.
And the threat of what might happen,
what could happen,
(audience cheering)
it's wearing you down.
Half of the things that you
though were going to happen
never did happen.
But if you allow those
thoughts to dwell in your mind
it will succeed at
robbing you of your peace,
robbing you of your joy,
robbing you of your life,
just because you thought yourself
into a nervous breakdown.
You thought yourself into depression.
You thought yourself into defeatism.
The mind is a battleground.
The fight is in your mind.
So I want to challenge you to waste
no more effort
wrestling with other people.
(audience yells)
Oh I lost you,
(audience cheers)
I lost you, you were doing
real good, I lost you.
(audience clap and cheer)
Your destiny, your
future is not predicated
on the decision of someone else.
(audience cheers)
You wasted too much of your life
trying to change other
people's mind about you.
(audience cheers)
It doesn't matter what
they think about you.
God is not going to bless
you by their opinion.
God is going to bless you
by how you see yourself.
(audience cheers)
Touch somebody and say I
believe I'm coming out.
- [Audience] I believe I'm coming out
- I don't know how long it's goin take!
I don't know what I'm going
to have to go through!
to lose along the way!
But I still believe that I'm coming out!
I've been broke, I've
been busted and disgusted
but I still believe that I'm coming out!
I'm locked up in prison,
they say I'll never get out,
But I still believe that I'm coming out!
I'm coming out, if I don't
have no where to stay!
I'm coming out if my
husband marry somebody else!
(audience cheers)
I'm coming out if I don't have no job!
I'm coming out, oh, oh!
The people who've became
the most successful
in our society,
are people who broke the rules.
You know there was no presidents
for 24 hour news cycle
until Ted Turner did it.
They're so many people
who got out of the box.
Look at Apple and the birth
of the whole notion of Apple.
Or Nike, I talk about in the book,
and the birthing of their corporation.
How they did something
with the tennis shoe
that had never been done before.
If you only base your
decisions on empirical data,
you can only repeat what
somebody else already did.
If you follow your instincts
and your own God-given creativity,
we can go where we have not been before.
Be strong and very courageous.
Be strong and be of good courage.
Be strong and possess the land.
Because God knows
that for what you're going to do
It is not by outer strength.
(audience cheers)
You understand, you understand.
Help me preach this
thing this morning, girl.
It's inner strength.
So my fourth point is you
got to have inner strength,
for this fight.
It's not your outer strength,
it's not by might
nor by power, but by My
Spirit, saith the Lord.
So you got to have that inner, that inner,
that inner, that gut
strength, that belly strength,
that devil-defying, come
hell or high water strength.
That roll me out in front of them
and I'll preach from a chair strength.
That tenacity to take a
lickin and keep on tickin.
That inner strength that
when I can't do as I would
I'm gon do as I can but
I'm not gon stop doing,
to the best of my
ability I'm gone stretch!
Hallelujah!
Be strong!
(audience cheers)
Strong!
I am afraid that too many times
we have pent so much focus
on teaching you to be good seed
that we haven't taught you,
the power of good soil.
And so when we come to soilless issues,
the seed ignores the soil.
We flick the channel,
that has nothing to do with me.
We close our eyes because
we have been taught to be
good seed.
But we have not been taught
to pay attention to soil.
And yet the Bible is clear,
Jesus says the sower
went for a sowing seed.
And some fell by the wayside.
Some fell amongst rocks,
some fell amongst thorns.
The whole text is about environment.
(audience cheers)
Look at you
and look at your environment.
Have you been positioned
to flourish?
Positioning has a lot
to do with flourishing.
To be in an environment, in
a family that supports you,
my sister and I were
talking the other day.
I was telling her what
an amazing person she is,
that all of our lives
together and all the things
that God did in my life,
not once in all the
years that I've known her
and she was there when Momma had me,
have I ever known her to be jealous of me.
(audience claps)
Not once, not ever.
She has always been my
cheerleader and my greatest fan.
And she said, how can I be
jealous of you, you're my brother
I said a lot of people have
siblings that hate them,
that are jealous of them,
that hope they choke!
And some of my development
has to be that God planted me
in an environment of people
that supported me.
My brother, my sister,
my mother, my father,
they all supported me.
You can have good seed!
But if you've been in bad soil,
people who hated you,
environments that denied you,
education that underserved you,
communities that limited you,
mentalities that poisoned you.
(audience cheers)
Do you hear what I'm saying?
If your soil wasn't right,
it doesn't mean that you're not right,
but if your soil wasn't right,
it's going to affect how
you root and how you grow.
And you might grow a
little bit the Bible says
you can grow for a while
but then the thorns
will choke you out.
Or the rocks will not have enough soil
for your roots to grow!
Are you blaming God
for something you ought to
be blaming the soil for?
You cannot take a peach seed
and plant it in a teaspoon of dirt
and expect it to grow.
Though the teaspoon of
the dirt is the same size
as the peach seed, it will not grow.
The seed will only grow when it is planted
in something bigger than itself.
And I want to know where are
you planted this morning?
Are you planted in
something bigger than you?
Or have you always been
planted in teacups?
Surrounded by little
dirt, little resources,
small-minded people,
narrow, limited places
that never let you stretch
to reach your capacity.
Sometimes you got to go where the corn is.
- [Charles Payne] You call
comfort in your book a cage.
- [Bishop T.D. Jakes] Comfort is a cage.
We use to be pioneers, that's
how this country was settled.
And we stop pioneering new things.
We stay where it's comfortable.
We play where it's safe.
We don't really get out into
the wild of the possibilities.
We stay in the confined cage of
that is tangible and touchable,
9 to 5 and that's it.
But we need more creativity
and we need to follow our instincts.
Now without that you may makes some money
but you won't find fulfillment.
Always go to something
bigger than yourself.
I'm wondering if you've been defeated
because you have been
given yourself, wholly,
to something that was
too small to hold you.
(audience cheers)
Have you thrust yourself
into a glass of water?
Have you leaped off the diving board
into a cereal bowl person?
Are you not guilty of immersing yourself
into things that were too
small to hold your vision?
Oh my God, this so good
I'm a get the CD myself.
Jesus sent him to throw
himself into something
that was bigger than his condition.
And he had to go to get to it.
He had to get out of his comfort zone.
My problem is so many times
you've thrown big ideas
at small people.
You've given big commitment
to cereal bowl people.
And you're trying to get your sight back
from a source that's too small to support
what you're willing to put in.
Is your investment bigger than the bank?
You should see the way
you're looking at me.
Is the reason you keep
being disappointed by people
is that you have wholly
thrown yourself into something
that was too small?
Jesus sends him to something
that is bigger than himself.
So he can wash his eye.
Are you trying to take a bath in a bowl?
David was a shepherd boy,
out there trying to
take care of the sheep.
And didn't have nothing to work with,
and a lion came against him
and he took a rag
and said this is the
kind of stuff you make
to fight back with
when you don't have nothing to fight with.
Have you ever gotten into a fight
and you didn't have nothing to fight with.
But you took what you had and you said
such as I have, I'm not
going let you take my stuff
my job, my opportunity, my life,
my family's legacy.
You after my family's legacy.
I'm not going to let you do it.
And even though I don't have nothing fancy
to fight with like a degree,
or like a million dollars,
or like a bunch of friends.
But I'm a roll up what I got and
I'm going to throw it at you.
(audience cheer)
Kill the lion,
kill the bear,
with this rag.
This rag, old dirty rag had thrown rocks
at everything that ever come against you.
If you live long enough a lot
of stuff a come against you.
And you got to, you got to
throw whatcha got at it.
You can't throw what you wish you had.
You can't throw what your neighbor had.
You got to throw what you got at it.
That's what separates
the men from the boys,
cause you got to throw what you got at it.
Don't tell me that you want something
if you're not willing to
throw what you got at it.
Since we're talking about business,
we're talking about money.
You can't be tribal
and be a global thinker at the same time.
The reason money is called currency
is that it needs to be able to flow.
And the issue is, do you
have a vision that flows
beyond people who look
like you, dress like you,
and vote like you?
And if you're going to
do business you can't do
segregated business and do it well.
If you've got a product
that you believe in
or message that you believe in,
or a movie that you believe
in or whatever it is,
you want to reach the
broadest amount of people.
And most people think tribally.
All of their relationships,
their contacts,
their associates are tribal and you block
the ability to succeed
when you block the ability
to communicate beyond your tribe.
Life demands that you pick up the pace.
If you don't pick up the pace,
you're going to be left behind.
I'm amazed at the people
that lack the flexibility
to pick up the pace.
They just get in a rut,
I stroll down here,
and I'm gon stroll back,
I'm gon stroll over here,
I'm gon stroll over there.
One of the most amazing
thing about the disaster
at Malaysia is that when
it happened everybody
had to pick up the pace.
All the news media had
to pick up the pace.
They were booking night
flights and flying over here
and flying over there.
Somebody had to work overtime,
won't be home for three days,
typing in the middle of
night, research going on,
because when something happens,
everybody got to pick up the pace!
That's why I can't deal with people
who cannot pick up the pace.
Don't be strolling when
I got a 911 on you.
I need people who can pick up the pace.
(audience cheers)
Flap your neighbor and
say pick up the pace!
- [Audience] Pick up the pace!
- Something is about to happen!
Pick up the pace!
Something is about to happen!
(audience claps)
I came to tell the young people,
pick up the pace!
Pick up the pace!
Something is about to happen!
The danger of low expectations
(audience cheers)
I would rather aim for
the stars and not hit them
than to not aim at all!
(audience cheer and clap)
I would rather go after it and not get it
then not go after it all!
I'd rather try and fail
then not try at all!
I don't want to live with the idea,
wonder what would have happened
had I done more with my life!
I'm going to go for it,
come hell or high water,
I'm going after my destiny.
Touch your neighbor and say run!
- [Audience] Run!
- You got to run after your destiny!
You can't stroll after your destiny!
You can't walk after your destiny!
You got to run!
Somebody holler run!
- [Audience] Run!
- You got to run!
You got to run!
You can't just wake up in the morning,
let me see what goin happen today.
I don't know what I'm a do,
I don't know what I'm a wear.
I don't know what I'm a cook.
I don't know where I'm a go.
I just woke up.
Aww you should stay in the bed.
Give the day to somebody
who's going to run after their destiny!
Give the day to somebody who has a plan
who has a strategy because
success is never an accident
and if you don't want
it, get out of my way.
Because there are some people
who want to do something with their life.
Who will run!
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Christopher asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
check out the link in the description
and you can go and cast your vote.
I also love to know which clip
resonated the most with you,
what lesson are you going
to take from this video
and immediately apply to your
life for two bits some how
leave it down the comments below.
I'm really curious to find
out what you have to say.
I just want to give a quick
shot out to Cyrus Webb.
Cyrus, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
and making that video
on your YouTube channel.
I really, really, really appreciate it bro
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
- [Cyrus] Your One Word,
by Evan Carmichael.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
(airplane soars)
I talked, you know, I
talked, you'd be surprised.
I talk a lot when I'm on stage,
I'm quiet when I'm at home.
I'm very quiet when I'm at home.
I tend to be a very quiet person.
You got to balance.
You can't just be rattling all the time.
(audience laugh)
Just nah, nah, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah.
It drives me crazy when
people talk too much.
It drives me crazy
when they just go on and on and on and on.
Because, see I pay attention,
And if you're not going
anywhere with this,
it drives me crazy.
One of the strengths of
preaching is outline.
Because an outline gives the
listener something to follow,
that has structure.
When you're all over the
place everything you're saying
maybe true but because
your message has no focus,
it becomes hard to follow.
It's hard to follow somebody
who doesn't have focus.
Where are we going with this?
What is the point?
What are you talking about?
Get to the point, what is this about?
And for a while you'll listen
because you're trying to
see if it has structure.
And when you figure out
that they're just talking,
and it has no relevance, you go deaf.